i am peter guzman president of the latin
chamber of commerce
i want to welcome everybody here for
this incredible announcement
that we're going to hear about today in
a few minutes
from our governor i just want to say
that
the chambers along with my colleagues
that are here and they'll be mentioned
we've been fighting every day for small
business that's what we do
we understand that the small business
community
is the lifeline it's the blood it's the
it's everything of our community
and so anything we can do to help small
business that's what we do with the
chambers
that's what we do at the latin chamber
of commerce we try to help small
business
keep them going through this horrible
time so today's announcement is going to
be a great one
and uh and i know the small business
community appreciates
the absolute hard work that our
treasurer before you never even heard of
a treasurer or what a treasurer did
you know now what zac conan's doing
that's for sure and you know what this
governor is doing
we're fighting for small business so
with that i am proud and honored
to introduce our governor from the great
state of nevada
steve sisilak thank you thank you
thank you peter it's a real honor to be
here this afternoon and i appreciate
the latin chamber taking leadership
putting this outdoors where it's a lot
safer for everybody
but thank you for your kind introduction
good afternoon and thank you all for
being here in this opportunity
i'm so glad to be joined here at an
event sponsored by the latin chamber
they're true spokespeople in our
community when they say small businesses
these chambers mean
small businesses i mean three four five
ten member
our employee businesses these aren't
just all the big casinos
and properties they represent every size
business
i also want to thank all the chambers
throughout the state
simply put we could not have done this
all without them and the contributions
that they make
each and every day they have been
steadfast steadfast partners throughout
this ongoing pandemic
by helping to educate our small
businesses keeping them in the loop on
changes with directives we've had
and helping them connect the resources
including the one we're going to talk
about today
under the leadership of treasurer conine
we've got the latin chamber here we've
got metro chamber i've got the henderson
chamber here
i've been either members are on the
board i think of all three of those
chambers at one time
or another and they do great work for
all of us so for all the chambers that
are here the asian chamber
all of them thank you for being here i'm
also pleased to be joined by
not only the treasurer but my friend
zach conan for this special
announcement that is aimed at nevada's
small businesses and nonprofits
as they continue to work with us on
their recovery efforts
and while director michael brown from
office of goed
could not be here with us i want to
thank hism and his team
for helping us to get to this point and
making this program
a reality throughout this pandemic our
small businesses have weathered the
storm with patience
grace and a keen sense of creativity and
ingenuity
when you think back at the beginning of
this pandemic we were just starting to
get food to go
from our restaurants and they came up
with a way to have curbside service when
you couldn't go inside
they came up with a way that you could
sign on the credit card and clean the
pens i mean they've been very adaptable
and we appreciate all that they've done
to keep the economy moving and to keep
people safe
many of our small businesses survive on
a very
very thin margin they're oftentimes
family owned and family worked with
labor
it's incumbent upon us to do everything
we can to help them bridge the gap
until we get through this health crisis
that we're facing
that's why it gives me great pleasure
today to announce the pandemic emergency
technical support grant
we are calling the pets program now i'm
not talking about pets as in cats and
dogs and tortoises
we're talking about the pets program
pandemic emergency technical support
qualifying businesses will receive up to
ten
thousand dollars to help them with their
expenses related to cobit nineteen
ten thousand dollars for some of these
businesses this is the opportunity to
stay open
online applications will be open on
monday october 19th
and businesses can comply can apply at
the goed website
at goed.mv.gov
i am incredibly proud of the treasurer's
office under the leadership of zac conan
and go it in the department of business
and industry for working together
to put a simple plan that will be easy
to apply for
so everyone can do it i would also
uh we have two members of the latin
chamber that are here today that i hope
will get to hear from a little bit
who are representatives of small
businesses who will benefit
from a pets grant i'd like to recognize
susan cortez
who runs nevada adult daycare she does
great work with our seniors
and i would also like to recognize hans
hibbert who owns jojo's jerky
he's an immigrant from croatia who built
a great business here in las vegas
susan hans and peter will be available
to talk to the media just after we're
done here
and i look forward to hearing about how
this program will help them
to continue to innovate during these
unprecedented times
if you are a small business that has
been hurt by this pandemic
and you need help with rent inventory
payroll
you've had to purchase protective
equipment ppe
or you've needed to retrofit your
business in order to keep your customers
safe
i urge you i implore you to apply for
the pets grant
and when developing this grant program
for small businesses
is important for all of us that we
prioritize some of the businesses
that have been hit the hardest by this
pandemic such as are disadvantaged
businesses
defined as women minority veteran
or disability owned businesses
additionally i recognize the hardship
specific categories of business types
have endured as a result of this
pandemic
and restrictions that have been put in
place on their particular businesses
which is why we made sure that nevada's
bars pubs
taverns breweries distilleries and
vineyards are prioritized
for access to this grant money across
the country and here in nevada
bars and pubs have faced restrictions
for the longest period of time
in order to keep people safe and i
wanted to do what we can to make sure
they are supported
as we move into the recovery stage
finally
the grant program will also be
prioritized for our hard-working
non-profit organizations in nevada
who have been providing invaluable
resources and support to our communities
it is important to make sure it is
important to me to make sure that our
businesses
who have made such significant
sacrifices
are able to access this grant program to
help them continue providing services
throughout the state
this program is completely 100
grant funded there's no requirement for
businesses to pay back this funding
and the money can be used for a wide
range of expenses
again online applications are open on
monday
and businesses can comply can apply on
the goed website
that's goed.nv.gov and before i turn it
over to zach
who's going to give us some more details
on the program i again want to thank the
chambers
for what they do chambers are the voice
of small businesses when you're a small
business owner
you can't represent yourself in carson
city in washington dc
and with the various elected officials
the chambers are your voice
and the chambers are your advocate in
your support mechanism
so we all know them a debt of gratitude
and we encourage you to join your local
chamber
support them because i assure you they
support you
and with that i'd turn it over to our
treasurer zach conan
thank you governor for the last seven
months
small businesses in nevada have been
among the hardest hit
by covet 19. small businesses have
helped
with the state's pandemic response by
listening to health experts
and making difficult decisions by
closing
and now reopening with reduced capacity
these actions have kept our medical
system from being overrun
and have kept nevadans alive as someone
who knows what it's like to sign the
front of a paycheck
i know just how difficult it can be for
business owners around the country to
make these sorts of decisions
having to choose between keeping
employees on payroll
or paying bills like rent and utility
costs can seem like an impossible
decision
that's why it's important that
businesses have access to funds
during this economic crisis let me be
clear
small businesses are the lifeblood of
nevada's economy
and small businesses will be the
backbone of our recovery
we have a responsibility to make sure we
do everything we can
to make sure those businesses stay safe
and stay open
since the beginning of the pandemic my
office has worked with other state
agencies
and local partners to take additional
risks off the table
for nevada families and small businesses
who are struggling
thanks to the leadership of governor
sisilak the support of the legislature
and the hard work of a very small but
very dedicated team
we've been able to provide mortgage and
rental assistance to thousands of
nevadans and small businesses
during this pandemic the next stage of
our economic relief plan involves
providing small businesses
and non-profit organizations especially
restaurants bars and taverns
with the financial assistance they need
to respond to the effects of this virus
that's why i'm excited to share details
of a new 20 million dollar program
which will be going live on monday
morning october 19th
at 8 a.m designing this program we had
three goals
one make it easy to apply for two make
it easy to understand
and three make sure that we get money
out the door to small businesses as soon
as possible
the pandemic emergency technical support
or pets grant
allocates 20 million dollars in
coronavirus relief funds to assist small
businesses
especially bars and restaurants impacted
by closure orders
non-profits arts and culture
organization and chambers of commerce
during this covet 19 health emergency
the program was designed to be flexible
so that businesses and non-profits can
adequately respond to covet 19
safely reopen and continue their
operations
using a simple online application at
goed.nv.gov
businesses should be able to complete
and submit
their application in less than an hour
let's talk timing
applications will open at 8 a.m this
coming monday
october 19th they will be open for two
weeks
closing on november 2nd at 5 00 pm
applicants must complete the form in
order to receive funding and i'd like to
thank all the chambers of commerce who
are going to be working to make sure
that small businesses have the resources
and the help they need in order to fill
out that application
now we worked very hard to make sure
that the application was simple
to ensure it can be completed by as many
nevada non-profits as possible
more information about eligibility
including an instructional video on how
to fill out the grant
is available on goed's website now
the pets grant will provide up to ten
thousand dollars for small businesses
and non-profit organizations
up to twenty thousand dollars for arts
and culture organizations
and up to twenty thousand dollars for
chambers of commerce grants under this
program can be used for a variety of
expenses
like ppe personal protective equipment
for employees and customers
payroll inventory rent
utilities retrofitting due to coven 19
and other operational expenses all
funding
through this program is awarded as
grants not loans
therefore a business owner does not need
to repay these funds
that they are awarded additionally there
are no restrictions on this program
for businesses and organizations who
have previously received
covid19 assistance so if you've received
uh ppp the paycheck protection program
the sba's eidl program
or any other state or local program you
are still eligible
for the pets grants funding will be
prioritized for disadvantaged
businesses bars taverns wineries and
non-profit organizations
within the priorities funds will be
awarded on a first-come first-served
basis
now for those of you who don't know
before i was your treasurer i was in the
service industry in fact
i spent my first job in nevada was in
laughlin 17 years ago
at a little restaurant we've discussed
different recovery efforts with
restaurateurs and bar owners around the
state
and i'm hopeful that this new program
will provide them with the assistance
that they very much need
there are a couple of important points i
want to drive home here and it would be
very helpful if you would share them
with all of your viewers
after reviewing the eligibility
requirements we encourage all small
businesses and nonprofits to apply
if they think they may be eligible do
not self-select
if you have questions about your
application or need additional
information
we will contact you as soon as we can
just start the process we will reach out
to you
additionally to all nevadans if you have
a small business that you love
a small restaurant down the street where
you had your first date with a
significant other
a small shop where you know the owner
and they know you tell them about this
program
get them to apply help us spread the
word and keep these businesses open
if you have any questions about the pets
grant or the application process
please don't hesitate to reach out to
the treasurer's office or the governor's
office of economic development
the best and fastest way to reach us as
always is email
ask at nevadatreasure.gov or by calling
1-800-336-1600
i want to thank go director michael
brown for all his help launching this
program
and the governor for his continued faith
and leadership i'd also like to thank
peter guzman from the latin chamber of
commerce
for their efforts to spread this program
uh through the latino community
and also to the other chambers of
commerce for spreading the word to your
members
well this program is just one of many
steps we are taking to aid in nevada's
economic recovery
we appreciate your help in spreading the
word and making sure that our businesses
get the help that they need our office
will continue to do everything we can
to make sure that we have a brighter
economic future for all nevada
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much zach we appreciate
that i want to once again thank
treasurer conan and director brown for
their help and effort
in getting us to this point thank you to
the chambers
that are instrumental not only in uh
today in getting the word out but
helping your members access this money
our goal is to be able to get this money
out to everyone and
the chambers are going to be
instrumental in making that happen and
again thank you to peter guzman and the
latin chamber for being our host today
this afternoon and we'll now be able to
take a few questions
if anyone has any
we'll ask go ahead zach
thank you for the question uh we
anticipate getting money out the door
about two weeks after the application
process
ends we've really been working to speed
up uh the process to make sure that
funds can get out as quickly as possible
to small businesses
and as far as how far the funds will go
these funds will cover about 2 000
nevada businesses at the funding level
now we desperately need help from our
federal government for additional
support
coronavirus relief funds and others to
make sure that we can help small
businesses
we need help with rental assistance and
infinite other needs so we
encourage everyone to push on your
federal delegation and on
uh the president for additional help
what would disqualify business from
getting a grant so
most businesses will be able and be
eligible for these
some businesses that wouldn't be
eligible for instance would be
businesses that have more than 50
employees businesses who had more than 4
million dollars in gross revenue last
year
is owned by a publicly traded company or
businesses whose purpose is illegal at
the federal level
these are really directed at truly small
businesses that can use the assistance
so yeah
yeah no there is a current the eviction
moratorium from the cdc level continues
uh they put it in effect after us and it
continues i think till the end of the
year
so that order that eviction moratorium
will stay in place
after hours expires this evening
no there's it would just be duplicative
anybody else where's our business owners
i want to
we've got business owner and we've got
two of you here right
that i want you to i need to see you
there chris uh be able to come forward
and uh ask these folks how they're doing
how it'll affect their businesses and
i think you'd be able to see some real
on the ground effect how this could be
uh activated so thank you everybody for
being here we appreciate you
thanks